>> Announcer: From the Library
of Congress in Washington D.C.
>> James Sweany: Good afternoon!
On behalf of the Humanities
and Social Sciences Division,
we welcome you to this book talk,
featuring Alonza Tehuti Evans,
who will discuss The Social
Impact of Prince Hall Masonry
in the District of Columbia:
1823 to 1900, based on the book
that he co-authored with
Alton G. Roundtree, entitled,
The History of the Most
Worshipful Prince Hall Grand Lodge
of the District of
Columbia: 1822 to 2016.
We thank you for joining us.
I'm James Sweany, Assistant
Chief of the Humanities
and Social Sciences Division.
I would like to take a moment
and express appreciation to all
who made possible this event today.
To Sibyl Moses, the
reference specialist
for African American history and
culture who organized this event,
the staff of the Humanities
and Social Sciences Division,
to Betty Culpepper [phonetic],
Leroy Bell, Darren Jones,
and to Michelle Wingfield
of the Office
of Special Events and
Public Programs.
We are especially appreciative of
Mr. Evans for coming to the library
to discuss his book with his.
The Humanities and Social Sciences
Division provides reference services
in collection development for
subjects that encompass information
in all formats for the arts,
humanities, social sciences,
local history, genealogy
in the main reading room,
in the library's Thomas
Jefferson building.
We now ask if you would please
check your phones and other devices
to assure that they do not
interrupt today's program.
This event will be filmed
and for future webcast.
Note that the staff of the retail
marketing office is selling copies
of Mr. Evans' book in the
lobby outside of this room.
And now, to introduce Mr. Evans,
Dr. Sybil Moses of the Humanities
and Social Sciences Division.
>> Dr. Sibyl Moses: Thank you, Jay.
Alright, good afternoon!
>> Audience: Good afternoon!
>> Dr. Sibyl Moses: Okay.
We are extremely grateful
for your presence.
And your presence is an indication
of a strong interest in research
on Prince Hall Freemasonry.
Today's presentation is important
because Prince Hall Freemasonry
is the oldest recognized
and continuously active organization
founded by African Americans,
with roots as early as 1775.
In observance of this year's
African American History theme,
the crisis in black education,
we dedicate this presentation
to three dynamic Prince Hall
masons, each a 33rd degree mason,
and each involved in combatting
the crisis in black education:
Charles Wesley, Amos T.
Hall, and Thurgood Marshall.
Charles Wesley served as
President of Wilberforce University
and Central State University, and he
wrote the first scholarly biblio --
biography of Prince Hall,
as well as the history
of the Prince Hall Grand Lodge
of Ohio, among other words.
Amos T. Hall was the Grandmaster
of the Prince Hall Grand Lodge
of Oklahoma from 1941
until 18 -- 1971.
And he served as President of the
Conference of Grandmasters from 1950
until 1964, a period critical in
the history of school desegregation.
It was Amos T. Hall who
encouraged Thurgood Marshall
to join Prince Hall Freemasonry,
and later to appeal to the masons
for their financial report --
support of the Civil
Rights Movement.
Thurgood Marshall, General
Counsel and Director
of the NAACP's legal defense and
educational fund, was also Director
of the Prince Hall Mason's
Legal Research Department.
This department funded the Civil
Rights Movement for a period
of 10 years, formerly, but had
been funding the movement before
and then continues to do so.
Later, Thurgood Marshall
became Associate Justice
of the United States Supreme Court.
Works by and about Charles
Wesley, Amos T. Hall,
and Thurgood Marshall
are represented
in the library's collections,
and on the bibliography
that you have with you today.
Our speaker today, Mr. A.
Tehuti Evans, is the co-author
with Alton Roundtree of, The History
of the Most Worshipful Prince
Hall Grand Lodge of the District
of Columbia: 1822 to 2016.
Mr. Evans and Mr. Roundtree
are to be congratulated
for their publication, because the
history of Prince Hall Freemasonry,
as is the history of many African
American charitable, benevolent,
and fraternal organizations, is one
area in African American history
that is difficult to
understand and explore.
Published sources are
largely inaccessible,
and where they do exist --
exist, they are often scattered
and incomplete, and Mr.
Evans will tell you,
they traveled throughout the United
States to pull together the research
that was necessary
to write that book.
Too often, the personal
papers of members
and prominent leaders
have not survived.
One exception being Judge
Robert Terrell's papers,
who was Grandmaster in the District
of Columbia from 1899 to 1902,
and his papers are held by
the Library of Congress.
Mr. Evans and Mr. Roundtree overcame
all the obstacles, and, today,
we have, I think, a
really definitive history
of the most worshipful
Prince Hall Grand Lodge
of the District of Columbia.
Mr. Evans is a prolific
author and editor.
He is a decorated Vietnam veteran,
and among other things, he has been,
and is known affectionately
as a cultural soldier,
a college professor, an
entrepreneur, and a social activist.
At Howard University, he majored
in engineering, and later served
as a military engineer in
the United States Air Force.
His awards are many, but the
one that caught my attention was
when the Washington Urban
League awarded Mr. Evans The Man
of the Year Award, and
promoted him to Director
of Employment and Training.
Although retired, Mr. Evans
has held several positions
in Prince Hall Freemasonry
in the District of Columbia.
He served as the Grand
Historian and Archivist of D.C.,
and also the Editor of the
Prince Hall Masonic Digest.
And as a side note, he is my go-to
man whenever I have a question
about Prince Hall Freemasonry that
comes to the Library of Congress
and I can't answer it, I'll
call Mr. Tehuti [laughter].
So, please join me in
welcoming A. Tehuti Evans.
[ Applause ]
>> Alonza Tehuti Evans:
Good afternoon, everyone!
>> Audience: Good afternoon.
>> Alonza Tehuti Evans: I would like
to take this opportunity, first,
to thank Dr. Sibyl Moses, Mr.
Sweany, and the whole staff
of the Humanities and Social
Sciences Division of the Library
of Congress -- Congress for the
invitation to speak here today.
But first, it is my privilege
to introduce the honorable,
Phillip David, Grandmaster
of Prince Hall Masons
in the District of Columbia.
[ Music ]
Accompanying my Grandmaster is
his wife, Mrs. Rosalie David.
[Applause] And the Deputy Grand
Master of Prince Hall Masonry
of the District of
Columbia, and my lodge mate,
Brother Quincy [inaudible].
[ Applause ]
As Sibyl pointed out, the
-- the book we produced,
The History of the Most
Worshipful Prince Hall Grand Lodge
of the District of
Columbia: 1922 to 2016,
was a six-year work of
research and writing.
But rather than talk about
the details of the book,
I'm going to talk about it in a
way in terms of the social impact.
Okay. Today I will -- the topics
of discussion, the early history
of Prince Hall Masonry here in the
District of Columbia: 1822 to 1849,
I'm going to talk about the
antebellum period in the district,
1850 through 1862 specifically.
The Civil War to Reconstruction,
1863 to 1880, and, finally,
the post-reconstruction to the
turn of the century, 1880 to 1900.
The early -- early history
of Prince Hall Masonry, well,
Prince Hall Masonry starts in
Washington D.C. officially in 1825.
But before 1825, there were
some things that occurred,
which caused the brothers
to turn to masonry
as a way to solve their problems.
When the federal government --
when the Constitution was written,
it provided for the
creation of the District
of Columbia for the federal capital.
After the 10 mile square was laid
out, and the government moved
from Philadelphia to
Washington in 1800, what we --
what they found were there were
some free African Americans living
within the borders of the
district, but there were no rules
or laws which applied to them.
There were only rules or laws that
applied to those still in captivity
in the institution of slavery.
But in 1816, a unique set of
experiences started to occur.
The founding of the American
colonization society.
Now this was done because the --
the plantation owners, slave owners,
had a problem with the
growing number of free Africans
that were beginning to
live in the country,
but there were no real
provisions for them.
The same was true here in
the District of Columbia.
So in 1816, they came up
with a plan, of course,
of shipping all the free
blacks out of America.
They -- they've got funding and
formed what we know as the Colony
of Liberia on the west coast
of Africa, and set about trying
to ship our free blacks to Liberia.
In the District, in
1821, following the lead
of the American colonization
society, the District Board
of Aldermen passed what we called
the harshest set of black codes,
which limited -- limited the
ability of free blacks to move
about in the District of Columbia,
and that caused quite a
concern to many free blacks.
So, in 1822, a man, John W. Prout,
a brother from Philadelphia,
called a meeting in his
house, in Georgetown,
and they had about 20 brothers
who came to the meeting,
and he made a plea to them that
they should form a masonic lodge.
And he used the example of what
the brothers had done in Boston,
Massachusetts as the reason why
they needed to form a masonic lodge.
What he talked about was,
one, the men who formed the --
who led the revolution, and who
were leading the government were
mostly freemasons.
Prince Hall, the founder of the
order, had found that he was able
to get citizenship status for
free blacks in Boston by writing
to the city council, having
quite freemasons on that council,
and he found a listening ear.
His first letter, you
can find it in the --
a book entitled, Letters of
Prince Hall, to this council was
to get permission to build a
school for the free black children
of Boston, and that was granted.
Later on, he wrote and asked for
permission to build a church,
and later on, this lodge
wrote and asked for permission
to build what we now know today as
The Historic African Meeting House.
So, steps to citizenship
were achieved in Boston,
which had not been
achieved anywhere else.
In 18 -- in 1797, the same plan
was shipped to Philadelphia,
Pennsylvania, where Absalom
Jones and Richard Allen,
who had founded the first
black church in Philadelphia,
came to Boston because they
were, again, suffering from some
of the same indignities because they
were not included in the legislation
as citizens of Philadelphia.
So they wanted to reproduce the --
what I call the Prince
Hall template,
to assert their rights
in Philadelphia.
At that time, the government
itself was housed in Philadelphia,
they didn't move to
Washington until 1800.
So while -- while there, a
lot of the brothers who --
who became Prince Hall
masons started to interact
with those masons in the federal
government who helped them interact
with the members of the
Philadelphia legislature
and the Philadelphia City
Council, Pennsylvania legislature,
Council, to get some rights
for free blacks in Philadelphia.
John Prout, being from Philadelphia,
knew what had happened, therefore,
he called for the brothers meeting
in his house in Georgetown in 1822
to try to replicate the
Prince Hall plan here
in the District of Columbia.
They wrote and asked for -- to start
a lodge, they got permission to do
so on June of 1825, social lodge --
what we call social lodge
number one, was established here
in the District of Columbia.
Upon establishing the lodge in
the District, the brothers began
to take their case to
court for citizenship.
The first of those actually took
place before the lodge was formed,
and that's the case of
William Billy Costin.
Bill Costin became
the first secretary
of social lodge number
one, but he, himself,
had a very interesting history.
The black codes, which limited his
ability to move about the city,
which prevented him from being
on the streets after 10 o'clock
at night, which prevented
him from assembling with more
than two other black men on the
streets, he felt were an injustice
to him, so he took
his case to court,
and a Judge William
Cranch heard the case,
and he ruled that Billy Costin was
grandfathered into conditions prior
to the black codes being written,
and all other free blacks who lived
in the District of Columbia were
not subject to the black codes
since they were here before
the codes were written.
Another one of the members
of the social lodge, in fact,
worked for Master John Prout
himself, was later accused
of [pause] helping slaves to escape
from the Underground Railroad
through the District of Columbia.
He was a schoolteacher, he could
read and write, and he was accused
of forging passes for
free blacks passing
through the district to go north.
From my reading of the
record, he was guilty.
That was part of what
he did, in fact,
social lodge number one
was one of the stations
of the Underground Railroad
through the District of Columbia.
However, the men who wanted to bring
in a handwriting specialist to look
at this document he
had produced to prove
that he had written the document,
the judge didn't allow it,
ended up fineing Brother Prout
50 dollars, and let him go!
Same judge, William Cranch.
Am I right?
Third -- a third brother
in this same lodge was
Brother Clements Beckett.
Now, Brother Beckett had purchased
some property in the District
of Columbia while he was still,
quote unquote, "a slave".
On this property, he built
up two rooming houses,
renting rooms to free blacks
running through the district.
Well, two white gentlemen decided
to try to take this property,
stating that a slave
couldn't own property,
and since this property was a
money-making piece of real estate,
they wanted to take control of it.
But -- but the case, again,
heard before John William Cranch,
Judge Cranch ruled that Brother
Clement Beckett lawfully owned his
property, and, therefore,
a precedent was established
that free blacks could own property
in the District of Columbia.
So it seems that John
Prout's original discussion
with the brothers was true, becoming
masons, interacting with masons
in the district, by the way, the
federal government, of course,
moved here in 1800, and there
were many masons on Capital Hall,
there were many masons
who came to Washington
to interact with the government.
And even the crisis of 1825,
known as the Captain
William Morgan Affair,
didn't negatively impact
the progress
that the brothers were making as
masons in the District of Columbia.
Let me...before going
to the -- the next step.
So between 1825 and 1845, while
white freemasonry was under attack
from the anti-masonic party and
other individuals who were disgusted
with the rumors of the murder of
William Morgan, he did disappear,
white freemasonry kind of
had their head underground,
but black freemasonry was growing.
In 1845, we created our
second lodge in the District
of Columbia, Universal Lodge.
At that time, Universal Lodge was
created in Alexandria, Virginia.
Now, Alexandria was still
part of the 10 mile square
of the district at that time.
So it was Alexandria, the
District of Columbia, where this --
the lodge of brothers were erected.
The reason they were erected there,
Alexandria being a port city,
several brothers had been made
masons overseas in England,
and they resided in Alexandria
and decided that the trip
from Alexandria into Georgetown
to meet with the brothers
in Washington was getting more
difficult, so they wanted a lodge
in Alexandria itself,
so that was created.
A year later, our third
lodge, Felix Lodge,
was created in Washington
D.C. What we --
what's called Western Washington.
So by 1846, we had three lodges.
Two years later, March of 1848,
these three lodges met in convention
and formed the Grand Lodge.
So, as of 1848, we had
the Union Grand Lodge
of the District of Columbia.
In terms of the expansion of masonry
here in the District of Columbia,
so by the time we reached the Grand
Lodge status, we were here to stay,
we weren't going anywhere.
Grand Lodge created
several civic organizations
as a strategy to fight
civil battles.
What I mean is this.
Instead of going into courts
or interacting with the people
in the city as a masonic
organization, the brothers decided
to create what's called the Social,
Civil, and Statistical Association,
the Bethel Literary Association,
and the Young Men's Literary
Association, so as they met,
they met under one
of those three titles
with other people in the public.
So there's a cover for what they
were doing, advocating again
for rights for free blacks
in the District of Columbia.
But by 1862, Abraham Lincoln
had been elected president,
and there was rumors afoot that he
wanted to send all the black folks
out of the United States of America.
So, Abraham Lincoln, through one
of his men, requested a meeting
of a delegation of free blacks
from the District of Columbia
to discuss a plan, the plan
he called, The Panama Plan.
And this -- in that meeting, John
T. Costin was a former Grandmaster,
in fact, he was the
second grandmaster
of Prince Hall masons
in the District.
Edward W. Thomas had
been grandmaster in 1861,
and then there was this
young up and comer,
real energetic young man
named, John F. Cooke,
Jr. His father founded
the second school
for free black folks in the city.
He, himself, had been run
out of the city, I'm sorry,
his father had been
run out of the city
in 1835 during what was
known as the Snow Riot.
But -- and he would become --
and he would be a future
grandmaster, from 1865 to 1873.
And of these five men, delegation,
two other men, Cornelius Clark,
who was in the Social, Civil,
and Statistical Association,
but he wasn't a mason.
And Benjamin -- Benjamin McCoy,
a minister and teacher, in fact,
he was the founding minister
of the Ashbury Church.
Well, Abraham Lincoln made a long,
a long plea to these men
explaining why, that after slavery,
he saw no way that free blacks
would want to live in a country
with people who had enslaved them.
He thought because of the
deaths during the Civil War,
that the former confederates
would never forgive blacks,
they would call -- charge
them with being the reason
that they lost relatives, so he had
gotten 600,000 dollars allocated
from the United States
Congress to ship all blacks
out of the United States, to an area
of Panama to -- well, it was not --
it wasn't called Panama at that
time, but to Panama, to become --
create a country of their own.
He thought both free blacks and
former slaves shouldn't live
in the country, and he needed these
five men's delegation blessing to go
about to the other
free black communities
and convince them to
buy into his plan.
This was August 14, 1862.
The five men delegation heard the
president's call, was polite, but --
and only one of the five
thought about, perhaps,
supporting the president's plan,
but since he didn't get the support
of the four or five men delegation,
Lincoln brought the plan up again.
So, again, part of the
impact of these men,
especially those Grandmasters
of Prince Hall masons,
with them saying no
to the president,
they wouldn't support the
plan, I assert it's one
of the reasons there is a black
Washington D.C. community today,
because if Lincoln
had gotten his way,
there would be no African
Americans in the country,
they all would have
been shipped out.
A lot of people, in a lot
of historical settings,
as our history is told,
especially during this period,
this Panama plan is never brought
up, the discussion that took place
with the president is never
brought up, and as far as I know,
no one else has made an
assertion about the impact
of them not accepting the
president's recommendation.
[Audience mumbling] New information
[laughter], again, [applause] --
again, in the -- in the book, we --
we cover the meeting, and, in fact,
we thought it was of such
importance, that we had the entirety
of the president's address through
the five men delegation in the book.
Okay. 1863 to 1880, talk a
little bit about that time.
Following the Civil War,
Washington D.C. was kind of unique,
because all of a sudden
blacks began to move
into very important
positions, like in other --
the reconstruction
governments across the south.
John F. Cooke, Jr., who
I already mentioned,
was appointed the Collective Taxes
for the District of Columbia.
William A. Taliaferro was elected
to the Common Council in 1868.
Carter A. Stewart was elected
to the Common Council in 1868,
and the Board of Alderman in 1869.
So for a time period, part of the
legislative leaders of the District
of Columbia were all [inaudible]
masons, and even though
in the history of the
District of Columbia,
you might see their names
mentioned, no mention is made
of the fact that they were masons.
Okay, again, John F. Cooke,
John F. Cooke, Jr., as I said,
was Grandmaster of the --
of the Prince Hall Grand
Lodge, he served two terms.
His first one was 1866 to 1873,
and he came back into Chair
in the east [phonetic]
from 18 -- 1876 to 1877.
He was appointed by
Ulysses S. Grant.
D.C. Chief Tax Collector serving
a 10-year term, from 1874 to 1884.
Cooke served as the
district delegate
to the Republican National
Convention in 1872 and 1880.
And he was also appointed to be
D.C.'s Jury Commissioner in 1889.
By the way, his wife
was also an activist,
Helen Appo helped found the
National Colored Women's' League.
Another one of our
brothers was James Wormley.
A lot of people don't know, but
James Wormley built and owned the --
one of the most prosperous hotels
in Washington D.C. in the 1870's.
His hotel was at 15th and 8th
Street Northwest, in fact,
it became a favorite for
Washington's rich and famous,
attracted by well-managed rooms,
renowned cuisine, in fact,
his turtle soup and seafood were
considered to be excellent dishes,
and amenities, such as
the first hotel elevator
and the first telephone
in the hotel was in --
in the Wormley Hotel
at 15th and 8th Street.
By the way, there's a school,
the Wormley School in Georgetown,
3331 Prospect Street,
which is there today,
was built and named in his honor.
1880 to 1900, because of Howard
University, a lot of elite blacks
who were attracted to
the District of Columbia,
men such as Dr. Daniel Hale
Williams, Dr. William A. Warfield.
In 1886, the Grand
Lodge at the District
of Columbia hosted the first
ever black industrial exposition.
That is it was a black
expo, 1886 right here
in Washington D.C. The only one held
in the country during that time,
but, again, the brothers of
the Grand Lodge at the District
of Columbia are the
ones who sponsored it.
It was held at the
Shallow Baptist Church.
Also during this time period, there
are a lot of writers, by the way,
this is a catalog from that -- from
that expo, basically the catalog,
first industrial exposition, the
colored citizens of the District
of Columbia, masonic fraternity at
Union Bethel Church, September 1886.
We're still trying -- I can't find
an original copy of the document,
but I but I have this
facsimile of it.
Some prominent freemasons in
D.C. during this time period.
Dr. Samuel R. Watts, in fact,
he was in Lodge number 25.
Let me back up.
Dr. Samuel R. Watts was the 29th --
the 25th grandmaster of the
Grand Lodge District of Columbia.
He was an internationally-known
doctor, and was very prominent --
prominently featured in his visits
to several countries in Europe.
Solomon G. Brown, once described
as probably the best employee
of the Smithsonian Institution.
In fact, the original director of
the Smithsonian Institution wanted
to appoint him as his successor,
and stated that he couldn't do
it because, him being black,
he knew that the white
power structure
of the government wouldn't allow it.
But in -- in most instances
where he's talked about,
he was the most know --
knowledgeable person
about the holdings
of the Smithsonian Institution
than any other employee
of that institution.
The next slide is Hamilton S. Smith,
he was the 29th Grandmaster
of masons here.
Hamilton S. Smith was also the
son of the last living master
of African Lodge 459 of Boston.
He was both a dentist and
photographer, and, in fact,
one of his pictures is -- graces the
cover of a recently-published book
from Massachusetts about the
Grand Lodge, the African --
the Prince Hall Grand
Lodge of Massachusetts.
With the authors just using the
picture on the book, and not knowing
who took the picture
or anything about it.
The irony about the picture,
doing my research, in fact,
I have the sister picture to the
one that's on the cover of the book.
The picture is of the most
[inaudible] Grand Lodge visit
to Prince Hall [inaudible].
And prominently in that picture
are a couple past grand masters
and some very important
people that are not named
on the cover of the book.
The picture on the book contains --
is a picture of the men and women,
the husband and wives, who
went to the -- on that visit.
The sister picture is just a
picture of the men, the masons,
who were on that trip, and,
again, that's part of our files.
The other gentlemen at the bottom,
Senator Blanche K. Bruce,
was a [inaudible] mason.
After -- after serving his term
in the -- in the government,
rather than go back to
Mississippi, he settled down
and became the leading socialite
here in the District of Columbia.
Next to him is the 23rd
Grandmaster of masons here,
this is Leonard C. Bailey.
Leonard Bailey was the
first black millionaire
in the District of Columbia.
He made his monies, he designed
a trussel of holding in -- for --
for a body wounds, he
invented the trussel
to hold the body part
in for the wounded men.
He also invented the folding army
cot, that, you know, in fact,
that folding army cot, I
slept on one when I was
in the military myself,
so it's still in use.
And he made millions,
and the millions
that he made made him the
founder of one of the first --
the first black banking at District
of Columbia, Capital Savings Bank,
which is down on F Street
Northwest, which pictured beside it.
And as Dr. Moses pointed out, two
other people I'd like to talk about.
During the course of writing an
article for the Masonic Digest,
I wrote one about Washington
D.C.'s second-most famous black
power couple.
And that is, at that time,
President Barack and Michelle Obama,
but the first Washington D.C. real
black power couple was Judge Robert
Heberton Terrell and
Mary Church Terrell.
Now, Robert Terrell, again, was
one of our grandmasters at the turn
of the century, from 1899 to 1902,
he was the first black
appointed judge here in the city,
and was very significant in helping
to found Sigma Phi fly [phonetic]
here in the District of Columbia.
But probably more famously known
was his wife Mary Church Terrell.
Mary Church Terrell
lived until 1954.
Her husband passed away in 1925.
She continued to be a leading
social activist fighting
against segregation in the city.
She was also a leading
women's suffragette.
In fact, on the side, it's kind
of a statement, she didn't want
to become a member
of the Eastern Star,
the female affiliate
of Prince Hall masons.
She told -- she was just
too forward-thinking,
she said, as an independent.
She was fighting for women's rights
and she wanted to be a leader
in that and she didn't want
to be in the organization,
but she was a leading proponent and
right up, just before her death,
she led marches here in D.C.
I personally remember --
remember her from the early
protests at Glen Echo Park.
If any of you older Washingtonians,
and know right outside
of the district, then Echo Park
was an amusement park that, again,
desegregated, wouldn't allow African
Americans to attend, and she marched
against that establishment.
So, during the course of
the 18th century, I'm sorry,
the 19th century, there are
many books that's been written,
literature written about blacks
in D.C. during that period.
Among those, Secret City:
The History of Race Relations
in the Nation's Capital,
by Constance Green,
an excellent book I suggest
everyone would enjoy reading it.
Another one, Aristocrat's of Color:
The Black Elite: 1880 to 1920,
though Willard Gatewood's book
wasn't talking just about D.C.,
the largest percentage
of the, quote unquote,
"aristocrats" of color were
residents here in the city.
Another book that talks a lot about
the blacks in Washington D.C.,
especially in the latter part
of the 19th century is Leading
the Race, by Jacqueline M. Moore.
By the way, all of these books are
here in the Library of Congress,
and most of them can still
be acquired through some
of the book selling
outlets in the city.
The fourth book, the Black
Anglo-Saxons, by Nathan Hare,
it's another that talks about
this unique black Washington
D.C. community.
What was unique about
it is that through all
of the negative circumstances that
people had faced, what gathered here
in the District of Columbia,
primarily due to the black
freemasons of the city,
was the most sophisticated, black
middle class of any jurisdiction,
any political jurisdiction
in the nation.
If you want to know where the,
quote unquote, "uppity blacks" were,
they were in Washington
D.C. [laughter].
And I use that term affectionately,
both said by members of the race
and -- and described by many
newspaper reporters as they reported
on the behavior of these people.
But the idea of being organized,
fighting as an organized body
for rights, and establishing
a -- what --
I like the term, a safe zone,
where black middle class people
could freely express themselves,
enjoy citizenship without all
of the pressures of black folks
in other parts of the south.
Remember, we're south
of the Mason-Dixon line.
There was nowhere else in the south
where blacks had as much freedom
and expression of themselves,
or created as much wealth
as what had happened here
in the District of Columbia.
At the foundation of what
made all of that possible,
were Prince Hall freemasons.
The fact that here in 18 -- 1822 was
when the -- when the process began,
and the fact that they organized
for their rights, stuck together,
it's -- it's quite an
achievement for that
to have occurred in the south.
In the north, they say that doing,
especially antebellum
days during the 1800s
that free blacks had more
privileges, that might be true,
but there was no city
anywhere else in the nation
where blacks had as much success.
During the period of captivity,
before the end of the Civil War,
and immediately after the end
of the Civil War, up to the turn
of the century, the most successful
blacks in America, as a group,
as a class, existed
here in Washington D.C.
And their story is a result of the
Prince Hall Freemasons of the city.
We -- we founded it, we're very
proud of what we have done,
and we only see more
success in the future.
Our next work will
address our successes
and impact during the 20th
century, but for this presentation,
we limit it to the 19th century,
because at that time we think it
reached kind of a peak of success
that we like to talk about.
Let me make sure.
No, okay, that was the last slide.
But I hope that this little,
short overview of the book,
you know, has been informative.
And before we go outside
to start signing autographs
or selling the book, I
would like to take this time
to entertain questions from
you about -- about...yes, sir?
[Inaudible background question]
Frederick Douglas did not become
a mason.
In fact, I would say Frederick
Douglas got, my personal opinion,
Frederick Douglas thought that
the [pause] form of what we do,
in practicing masonry, the substance
of what masonry is,
was a waste of time.
He thought that man should be
spending more time outwardly working
for the freeing of
those in captivity.
So, he -- but his son was a mason.
But he didn't.
Yes ma'am?
[ Inaudible Background Question ]
Yes! [Laughter] That's a -- yeah,
well...yeah, okay, let me --
let me answer the -- let me
answer the question this way.
No, well, it's a very important
question because, often times,
a lot of -- a lot of African
American historians shy away
from this point.
The mixed race African Americans
are 99.9 percent a result
of white plantation owners
having sex with captured women.
Today, it would be called rape,
legally, because you have power
over somebody and you have
sex with them that way.
I mean, they don't have
the power to give consent,
since they're in captivity.
So, a lot of these plantation
owners who had children
with their captive women both
respected and loved their children.
And in many cases, they gave them
a [inaudible] upstate, as it were,
and sent them up north to
live, there such, right?
Washington D.C. became one
of the primary landing places
for a lot of mixed race people.
As an example, I'll talk
about Mary Church Terrell.
Mary Church's grandfather
was a white man
that had a son with a black woman.
He loved his son, brought him up in
his business, gave him money to --
he'd stay right -- yeah, I think
it was St. Louis or Kansas City
where his son even became very
wealthy, as such, and, you know,
and they -- his daughter married,
Mary Church, she was a feisty,
young woman, they sent her off
to college, and her grandfather
and father took her
on a tour of Europe,
following her graduation
from college, as such.
But a lot of people who looked
at her when they see her,
they wonder what her ethnicity is.
In fact, another one of the
stories of our fraternity
across the board is
that in the early days,
a lot of the leadership were
mixed race brothers and --
were mixed race black men
because of that one phenomenon.
Not that they didn't escape and run
north, like a lot of blacks did,
but a lot of them were actually
given their freedom by their fathers
and sent north to other cities
where they could live a decent life.
And so I do understand, by looking
at the pictures, you could think,
wow, they all -- they're not,
quote unquote "dark black".
But because of the one-drop rule
passed by the government, you know,
like the real status, if you
had one drop of black blood,
no matter what you look like,
you were considered black.
And a lot of people -- a lot of
people of mixed race, a lot of --
a lot of mixed race
people don't look black.
In fact, one of the phenomenons
that occur in this country,
there's a term called passing,
and a lot of black folks --
a lot of people who, by law, would
be considered by black are passing
for white, because
if you don't know --
you don't know their DNA or blood
line, you would never be able
to tell that they had
one drop of black blood.
But that's a good question.
Yes, sir?
[ Inaudible Background Question ]
Oh, beautiful question.
Well, William [inaudible]
was the grandson
of Martha Custer Washington.
Marth Custer's father
brought him into the world.
Alright? So he -- Marth -- [pause]
her father, Martha's father,
alright, was his father also.
Now, Martha had a mixed -- Martha's
sister was a mixed race woman,
Native American and black.
And when Martha got married, her
father gave her her step sister,
you know, as her captive.
After Martha was married and had a
child, her son, when he got of age,
he raped his aunt, not
knowing it was his aunt.
Alright? And so her son had a
child with her stepsister, so,
William [inaudible] was
both Martha's grandson
and nephew [audience
mumbling] as such.
Now here was such a
high-spirited and intelligent man,
that when both George and Martha
died, he left the plantation
of his own free will and
moved into the district.
He became one of the most trusted
men at the Bank of Washington.
In fact, a lot of widowed women with
monies would call on him to come
to their homes -- would send
for him to come to their homes
and get monies that he
would go down and deposit
in the Bank of Washington.
By the way, the Bank of Washington
is, today, is in the exact spot
where it was during Billy's life.
And he had the respect of a
lot of whites at that time
who knew what his parentage was.
So they knew that he was a
Custer's [inaudible], and, in fact,
after Martha died, the
[inaudible] sisters,
or the Custer's sisters
had Billy do all
of their banking and official work.
They didn't trust their --
they trusted him more than they
trusted their own blood brother.
So he had quite a status.
In fact, when he died in 1842,
he was the first African American
to have -- or to be eulogized
on the floor of the House
of Representatives, and the man
who eulogized him was the former
President and newly-elected House
of Representative, John Quincy
Adams, eulogized him in 1842
on the House -- on the floor
of the House of Representative.
And then the newspapers
of the day, you know,
like his funeral procession was
covered by all the local media,
in terms of the respect
of the number of people
who turned out to honor this man.
Both black and white, he was one
of the most honored
men during his lifetime
in the District of Columbia.
Yes, sir?
[ Inaudible Background Question ]
Hard -- yeah, it was
a six-year effort.
A lot of the works are in
the masonic library in our,
thank god for the grandmaster
of masons of our back
in the late 1800's who had
enough foresight to say
that it was intention to create the
best masonic library in America.
And he told his man, hey, he
didn't care about the rules,
he wanted all of the proceedings
of the black masons in the country,
as well as the white masons.
So thanks to him, a lot of
original records are copies
of the original records
at our masonic library.
There's another process
in masonry where the --
we have a CCFC, a chairman
[laughing] -- chairman --
chairman of the committee on foreign
correspondence whose responsibility
it is to communicate
with other grand lodges.
Whenever a -- when we printed
our proceedings for what we did
for the year, our chairman
would send copies,
or at least write a summary of what
we had accomplished for the year,
and send those summaries
to other grand lodges.
So we had to go out and look in
the records of other grand lodges
for a CCFC report, and
I guess the other thing,
my background as a historian.
I went back to school after
engineering and got degrees
in history and philosophy.
But in studying African American
history, prior to becoming a mason,
a lot of these people knew
their place in society
and contributions they had made,
for my background as a historian.
I didn't know they were masons!
Until six, you know,
within the last six years.
By the way, I was asked,
I volunteered to assist
Brother Roundtree, in fact,
I was asked to volunteer
because of my background
as an African American historian,
to Brother Roundtree is a researcher
and a writer, but wasn't
necess -- didn't, at that time,
consider himself a historian.
So, we wanted to add this flavor to
the works that would be produced.
So I was quite surprised to
find that a lot of the people
who were already heroes of mine
from black history were
also [inaudible] masons.
And so, you know, so it was kind
of like a cross fertilization.
My background plus the masonic
records, my method of research added
to Brother Roundtree's
method of research,
it was definitely a
work of collaboration.
Yes, ma'am?
[ Inaudible Background Question ]
Oh, yes! John T. Costin, as an
example, was personally responsible
for uplifting blacks in Georgia.
He left D.C. and was called a,
quote unquote "carpet bagger",
but after -- after the
war, he went to Georgia,
traveled all over the state
organizing black folks,
both for the purpose of organizing
them to vote to get empowerment
in that way, and also in community
meetings, teaching them how
to organize their resources
for their own upliftment.
Another gentleman,
Richard Howell Gleaves,
who was a past national
grandmaster and from Philadelphia,
Pennsylvania, went
to South Carolina.
In fact, he was elected
the Lieutenant Governor
of South Carolina during
the reconstruction era.
He as from Philadelphia,
Pennsylvania, but he came back
and settled down, became
a member of --
of the our body in Washington
D.C., but his personal wealth
and knowledge helped uplift the --
I did it again, uplift the
brothers in South Carolina.
So there was a way that the people,
our knowledge and organizing skills,
went south to organize in the south,
the newly-freed Africans
there, right?
To help them get their act together.
Another thing that people might
not know, but both Absalom Jones
and Richard Allen of the African
Methodist Episcopal Church,
were both grandmasters of masonry
in the state of Pennsylvania,
and they sent riding bishops into
the south to organize churches.
The two elements of what makes a
community, where they organize men
as masons, and the church.
They was the anchor for spiritual
development, as such, right?
And, again, those ideas, [inaudible]
from [inaudible] masonry went
to settle and help create the
successful communities of blacks
in the south following
the Civil War.
Yes, sir?
[ Inaudible Background Question ]
Okay, well, because of the
grand lodge being here in 1867,
I think when [inaudible] was
formed, that the -- the --
those men who created the
institution depended on a lot
of the -- the brothers
in [inaudible] masonry
to help give them a way
and get them set up.
Dr. Warfield, who set up Howard
University's Surgery Department,
was also one of our grandmaster,
a grandmaster of masons, alright,
here in the District of Columbia.
I don't have a list
of all the professors,
but there was always
a close relationship
between our grand lodge
and [inaudible] Howard.
In fact, from 1865 until 1925, if
you were an African American man
in America, the highest social
status you could have was being a
mason, being a [inaudible] mason.
The reason I put that date and line
in there is because from 190 --
from 1904 through 1925 is
the period of the creation
of the Greek fraternities on
college campuses, and over time,
even though each one of them used
our procedures and our handbooks
to create their organizations, as
such, right, as one became educated
through time, in the minds of some
people, being a [pause] Greek --
in a Greek fraternity was the
highest status than being a mason.
But about, I would
say from 1920 to 19 --
well, until 2016, or until today,
one of the most [inaudible]
statement that you can make is
that you're a double brother.
Now, double brothers are mason and
an omega or mason and an alpha,
a mason and a cappa, or what
have you, but double brothers.
So, [laughter], you know, it's
like we -- we created them, they --
they've come back and we've joined.
So we both have the -- the frater
-- the college fraternal order
and [inaudible] masonry all have
the same goals for our communities.
There's [inaudible]
in moving forward.
Yes? That's the last...alright,
last question.
Yes, sir?
[ Inaudible Background Question ]
Okay, well, I'll put it this way,
is the -- when the masons of --
of the revolutionary period,
designed the documents,
which are the foundation
of this country, in fact,
13 out of the 39 men who created
the Constitution were masons.
The first country in the world
to have a constitution is the
United States, and the idea came
from the fact that masonry was
run by Anderson's Constitution.
And many of the elements in the
U.S. Constitution duplicate what's
in Anderson's Constitution.
But the -- what we call America's
original sin, not just slavery,
but the discrimination that slavery
caused, [inaudible] tenants say
that in the country, that
all men are created equal.
The government didn't practice
that, and though freemasonry is a --
is an organization itself, which
states that all men are brothers,
so we don't -- we only deal
with each other based on what's
in our hearts, in those days, these
three [phonetic] didn't do that.
So there was discrimination.
There were whites who wouldn't --
who didn't allow their interaction.
My co-author wrote a piece several
years ago, called two faces,
one public and one private,
in which -- which --
what was pointed out is that there
have always been white masons
who worked with and helped
black masons move forward.
But at the same time, there
have always been white masons
who did everything they could to
prevent us from moving anywhere,
and who denied our
legitimacy, as such.
Right? So that's internal politics.
So, in America, as opposed to
anywhere else in the world,
what's called [inaudible]
freemasonry is talked
about as black freemasonry or
African American freemasonry.
But the truth of the matter is
both groups practiced the exact
same thing.
Both groups do.
But, again, the legacy of racism
and discrimination has
-- is still with us.
There are -- of the 50 states in the
country, there are 8 grand lodge,
or white masons, primarily
in the south,
who don't recognize
black freemasonry
as a legitimate fraternal
organization.
Therefore, when we talk, we
have to talk about white masonry
and black masonry and we
bring up those circumstances.
Okay? Well, thank you very much!
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Sibyl Moses: You
know, I really would
like to thank Tehuti Evans
for honoring our invitation,
because every time he speaks, he
speaks as he has spoken today.
Okay, his mind is so fertile,
and it's such a wonderful experience
every conversation you have
with this man, is so
enlightening, and what he has done
with Alton Roundtree is enable
us now to tell the story
of African Americans in
the District of Columbia,
because now historians can now
take their work and integrate it
into future histories, and this is
what is needed across the country.
This is what is needed.
We invite you to come back again.
While you're here, please go
down and register in Room 140
to become a registered reader
of the Library of Congress,
so that you can come back
and use our collections.
Please, also, use the
bibliography that we have prepared
to see what we actually have
in -- in our collections.
It's -- it's unbelievable when
you look and dig what is here.
Just the other day, I called
Tehuti, and I said, you know, I --
I found a letter by John Cooke,
you know, is this our John Cooke?
And he said, yes.
It was John Cooke, Sr., it's
a letter, 1837, downstairs,
and the curators and the manuscript
collection have pulled that document
out along with some other
documents so that we can go down
and actually see them, alright?
So what I have for you, Mr.
Evans, and for you, Mr. David,
is a copy of one of the [pause] --
a copy of one of the reports
that Thurgood Marshall made
to the NAACP's legal defense
fund, talking about the money,
actually documenting, it was
his report to the conference
of grand masters where he
documents what the funds
that the Prince Hall masons gave
to the NAACP's legal defense
fund actually achieved.
Okay, and we know that there were
over 400 school desegregation cases.
[Applause] So, you have that, okay?
And on a final note, my father
was a double brother [laughter].
He left Howard, he was
drafted while he was a student
at Howard University to go to
Tuskegee Army air-flying school
as a Tuskegee airman, and while
he was in Tuskegee, Alabama,
he became a Prince Hall mason.
He went through Lewis Adams Lodge,
and for those of us who know,
Lewis Adams was one of the
founders of Tuskegee Institute,
along with Booker T. Washington, and
so they named the lodge after him,
and my father went
through that lodge,
and one of the things
he has always told us is
that to be a balanced black
person, you have to belong
to the craft and to a fraternity.
That's what he would say.
He said, because there you get
the representation of all of us,
and he said that Prince Hall
freemasonry was the gatekeeper
of our culture, and you can hear
from Tehuti's presentation
today how it is.
You cannot tell the story of
African Americans in this country
without telling the story
of Prince Hall freemasonry.
So, thank you, again, for coming.
The book is available outside,
and we hope you will come back!
[ Applause ]
>> Announcer: This has
been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.